hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
you are given a normal die and a blank
die
label the blank die using the numbers 0
to 6 so that when you roll the two dice
the sum shows each whole number from one
to twelve with equal chance
you can use a number more than once or
not at all
so you could label the faces one two
three four four five
but you do have to label all six faces
of the blank die
this was asked as an interview question
at amazon
before i go any further i want to share
an important point about these
probability videos
i received an email from dr gleb yakubov
who's an assistant professor at the
university of nottingham in the uk he
writes
hi i just wanted to let you know i
mentioned your puzzle what is the
distance between two random points in a
square in my recent research paper
i thought it would be good to show how
your channel can not only stimulate
students including those in my class but
also stimulate research questions
thank you so much for letting me know
i know probability is not everyone's
favorite subject but these videos are
important so i'll share probability
videos from time to time
so going back to the puzzle
pause if you'd like to give it a try and
when you're ready keep watching the
video to learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
we'll get started with an observation
when you roll two six-sided fair dice
you get six times six which equals 36
equally likely outcomes
let's make a little table of this
the standard fair die will have the
faces one through six
the mystery die will have 6 unknown
faces
we need these 36 sums to be divided into
12 equally likely sums because we need
the numbers 1 through 12 to occur with
equal chance
so each sum has to appear 36 divided by
12 which equals 3 times
we need 3 entries of 12 3 entries of 11
and so on all the way to 3 entries of 1.
now how do we get 3 entries of twelve
well six is the largest number that we
can put on the mystery die
so notice the only way we can get a sum
of twelve is six plus six
so that means we're going to need three
faces to be labeled with six that's the
only way we can get three sums of twelve
now by similar logic how can we get a
sum of one
well zero is the smallest number for the
mystery die and the only way we can get
a sum of one is if we do zero plus one
so we're going to need three faces to be
labeled as zero
so now we've actually labeled all six
faces
do we have a solution
let's fill in the rest of the sums
the first row goes from one to six and
the next two rows will be the same
then this row will go from seven to
twelve and the next two rows will be the
same
and look at this table carefully
each sum from one to twelve appears
exactly three times and by magic we have
found the answer
the mystery die needs to be labeled with
three faces of zero and three faces of
six
so we kind of lucked into the answer
and that's good for this problem and it
would be great in an interview
but
how would you solve this problem in a
more systematic way
i want to show you another method it'll
be a lot more complicated but it's a
powerful tool to solve such problems
the method is called probability
generating functions
if z is a discrete random variable on
the non-negative integers and p i is the
probability that z is equal to i
then we define the probability
generating function of z as follows
it'll be the polynomial with terms p sub
i multiplied by x to the power of i
so let's create the probability
generating function for the fair die
well the fair die takes the realizations
of one through six
and each is equally likely to occur with
a chance of 1 over 6.
so what's its probability generating
function
what we do is we attach the coefficients
of x of i to the probability of i
we can now factor out one over six
so here's the probability generating
function of the fair die
we can similarly create the probability
generating function of the mystery die
and here's the probability generating
function of the sums
so why have we done all this it seems
like we've made the problem more
complicated well here's the key property
the generating function of a sum of
independent random variables is the
product of the individual generating
functions
so we have d of x multiplied by m of x
is equal to u of x
if we divide both sides by d of x we can
solve that m of x is equal to the ratio
of u of x over d of x
so in order to solve for this mystery
die we can take this polynomial division
and i can just hear some students saying
when will we ever need this
well it looks like polynomial division
could actually help you get a high
paying job
so how do we solve this problem
let's go through the steps
i'll just give an outline form
we want to divide u of x by d of x
so notice the highest power in u of x is
x to the power of 12 and that's
multiplied by 1 12
and here we have x to the power of 6
multiplied by 1 6.
so to get the highest powers to match
we're going to multiply by one half of x
to the power of 6. so when we do that
we're actually going to eliminate all of
these terms going from x to the power of
7 to x to the power of 12.
so what are we left with well let's
expand out u of x
the next highest power will be x to the
power of six
we have one twelfth of x to the power of
six
and here we have one sixth of x to the
power of six
so we're going to multiply this by one
half which is also equal to one half of
x times zero
we multiply this out and then we
subtract and we actually cancel out all
of these terms so we end up with no
remainder
so that's it m of x is equal to one half
multiplied by x to the power of zero
plus one half multiplied by x to the
power of six
now the mystery die has six faces so
we'll rewrite it as three over six times
x to the power of zero plus three over
six times x to the power of six
and now we can read off the coefficients
to c the mystery die needs to be labeled
with three faces of zero and three faces
of six
incredible
i think this is a great interview
question because you could solve it with
the high power tools of probability
generating functions but you could also
solve it logically considering how the
mystery die needs to be labeled to get
the correct sums
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]